[Musique]
bienvenue dans 2022 2022 vu par marie le
bec bonjour je vous êtes la député de la
4e circonscription des yvelines alors on
va parler de cette année qui s'ouvre va
peut-être aussi revenir un petit peu en
arrière quelques quelques instants
d'abord cette 4e circonscription on peut
opposer d'abord elle a une histoire
c'est il ya eu parmi vos prédécesseurs
michel rocard qui a été une lutte à ses
conceptions qui avait battu boris cause
du vide qui sortait juste de matignon
c'est une circonscription assez
particulière puisqu'elle a été beaucoup
hors des coupés au fil du temps elle a
un bassin de vie qui est pas tout à fait
le sud de la circonscription n'a pas le
même bassin de vie que le nord de la
circonscription où c'est plutôt où ils
sartrouville alors que le sud
seine-et-marne et le roi et c'est
peut-être plus proche de versailles donc
il faut faire un peu le trait d'union
avec cette scène qui sépare les deux
bouts de cette circonscription est
paradoxalement toutes les villes sont
dans la même commune communauté
d'agglomération saint germain boucles de
seine est donc aussi la nécessité de
réussir à créer du lien entre tous les
habitants cette circonscription pour
google c'est bien vous y avez étudié en
fin de votre cause de la nature moi j'ai
grandi j'ai grandi à louveciennes j'ai
été
alors c'est toujours sur cette sorte de
bassin de vie j'étais scolarisé à
saint-germain-en-laye j'étais scolarisé
à chatou au bon sauveur donc oui j'ai
beaucoup d'attachés c'est aussi pour ça
que j'étais très fier d'y être élu et de
la représenter alors vous êtes présenté
en 2017 vous aviez rejoint emmanuel
macron qu'est ce qui vous a décidé à
vous présenter eh bien je veux dire que
au début enfin moi j'ai toujours aimé la
politique l'engagement j'ai que ça
représente et de l'ump je venais de 2
voilà de l'ump puis devenu les
républicains
j'avais quitté les républicains parce
que je trouvais qu'on était un peu en
bout de course au niveau des idées et
finalement aujourd'hui encore on écoute
or hier le même le meeting de valérie
pécresse ne me suis pas dit où retrouver
et j'avais été très séduit par le
discours des manuels mâcon donc je me
suis initialement engagés pour
développer le mouvement en marche en
2016 dans tout les yvelines c'était une
expérience très riche et très
intéressante et puis ensuite ce qui m'a
vraiment décidé au delà du fait que
j'aime cet engagement fin cette forme
d'engagement certains préfèrent
l'associatif moi j'aime l'engagement
politique c'est vraiment le aussi
l'appel des manuels mâcon qui est dit
moi je veux faire de la parité réelle et
aujourd'hui quand je regarde les
candidatures qui me sont soumises pour
choisir mes parlementaire il ya beaucoup
d'hommes et très peu de femmes et je me
suis dit il est aussi temps d'arrêter de
se mettre nous mêmes le plafond de verre
moi à l'époque pensaient que j'étais
trop jeune et que je la suite citerai
pas forcément l'adhésion j'avais avait
que 26 ans mais ça c'est comme
on n'est pas habitué la classe politique
est plutôt été plutôt jusqu'à la plage
est un peu masculine et je pense que le
tour de force dans les yvelines ça a été
pour le mouvement la république en
marche d'investir majoritairement des
femmes sur les douze circonscriptions il
y a il ya trois hommes donc le reste ce
sont uniquement des femmes soient issus
du modem soit ici de la république en
marche et puis aussi je trouve de faire
confiance à des jeunes qui avaient envie
de s'engager cet espace de débats
pendant la campagne
certains trouvé ça super enthousiasmant
et notamment d'ailleurs chez les plus
seniors j'ai trouvé ce discours là ce
qui était plutôt agréable et puis
d'autres médias que j'avais très peu
d'expérience de la vie personnelle
professionnelle ce qui était aussi une
réalité on va pas s'inventer une
expérience dont je leur ai dit bah voila
moi je vous demande pas je vous démontre
pas que j'ai de l'expérience mais faites
moi confiance et et j'essaierai de vous
montrer que je suis capable d'être à la
hauteur donc on les élections approchent
on verra j'espère avoir alors vous êtes
assez facilement élu à plus de 60% au
deuxième peau
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit le ce jour
de juin vous êtes dit ça y est je suis
député grève j'avoue que ça c'est plus
chaud au premier tour parce que j'étais
à 48% au premier tour j'y croyais pas je
suis totalement tombé des nues et on
sait jamais on sait jamais ce jour il ya
un élan la main la présidentielle mais
bon de toute évidence la première fois
qu'on est candidat on n'est jamais
certain d'été lui on n'est même pas
certain de faire les 5% qu'il faut pour
être remboursé de ses frais de campagne
c'est quand même un peu un enjeu moi
c'est c'est uniquement de l'apport
personnel je n'ai pas fait d'en prendre
ça crée un peu toutes mes économies qui
le mettait sur la table est-ce qu'ils
auraient un peu français mon conjoint de
ce qu'on avait aussi projet d'acheter à
bien donc si je n'avais pas été à
ça aurait été une autre aventure
et puis ça a été aussi une campagne face
à guînes fournier qui était le maire de
chatou quelqu'un d'implanter de
respecter dans le territoire donc pas
pas une bataille facile mais oui
franchement quand j'ai vu les premiers
résultats et surtout la marge d'avancé
que j'avais je suis totalement enfin
elle était très surprise et et c'est
très émouvant parce que c'était oui
quand même là la flaque capacité à
démontrer que on pouvait faire bouger
les lignes je crois que pierre lequiller
mon prédécesseur était quelqu'un de très
apprécié et très respecté qui a été élu
pendant tant d'années lupin une
trentaine d'années ce qui est à la fois
des montres je pense le respect qu'il
avait de la part de ses concitoyens mais
aussi peut-être ce qui est un peu
malsain dans notre démocratie c'est à
dire cette absence de limite dans le
cumul dans le temps et finalement voilà
ces espèces de très longs continuent
témoin pendant la campagne j'ai utilisé
cet argument peut être un peu mesquin je
vous reconnais mais j'ai dit beaucoup
pierre lequiller il est élu depuis une
trentaine d'années il a été élu moi je
n'étais pas encore né il a été le
prévenu la première fois député en 1986
je crois de mémoire et sykes a fait
prendre conscience aux gens que aussi la
richesse de la vie politique c'est de
changer aussi de temps en temps c'est
ses représentants je crois que un mot
justement sur le cumul parce que parfois
on entend souvent dire ben ces deux
nouveaux députés notamment lrm qui
justement est pas le cumul ne sort que
député il son apport sur le bar fois ils
ont pas conscience des réalités vous
pensez qu'il faut quand même continuer
dans cette voie du non cumul moi oui je
pense que c'est très important dans
cette affaire de non cumul et moi je
suis pour un non cumul dans les
fonctions et dans le temps je crois que
ça a contribué à une forme de confusion
de qui a quel rôle dans notre démocratie
je crois que c'est très important de
savoir que les représentants locaux
votre mère votre conseiller
départemental régional c'est celui qui
va faire la mise en place des lois qui
sont votées c'est le pouvoir exécutif
un peu comme le même pouvoir kiev 1 qui
est partagée finalement avec celui du
président de la république et puis le
parlementaire c'est le pouvoir
législatif c'est lui qui va voter les
lois c'est lui qui va donner le cadre
les grandes orientations et je crois que
c'est très important de deux séparés je
crois que c'est aussi important dans le
temps parce que bien sûr la politique ça
s'apprend dans un système qui est très
complexe peut-être qu'il faut travailler
sur cette version ne suis pas dedans il
faut parfois du temps c'est pour ça que
je ne suis pas pour un mandat unique en
plus cinq ans ça passe très vite mais je
crois qu'il faut aussi s'interroger sur
la durée dans lequel pour laquelle on
s'engage parce que c'est aussi ce qui
fait vivre le débat de re régulièrement
renouvelé ses personnalités les gens qui
vous qui vous représente et de pas
considérer finalement que
la figure qui va vous représentez pour
les 30 prochains
alors on parle de ba2 du temps qui passe
vous arrivez à la fin de ce mandat vous
avez vous avez quand même envie de
continuer oui j'ai déjà ce
cette ambition de pouvoir continuer un
certain nombre de réformes qui ont été
engagées par le président de la
république il ya beaucoup de combat mais
on va dire que moi je me suis beaucoup
engagé pour les questions économiques
c'est c'est ce qui m'intéresse aussi
dans la vie politique cet équilibre
entre le monde politique et le monde
économique il ya encore des choses à
faire il ya la réforme des retraites sur
laquelle nous avons dû nous arrêter à la
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
et je pense que c'est fondamental qu'on
arrive à la réforme et il ya la question
de notre balance commerciale
et vous savez que les clippers problème
est un de mes grands combats de ce
mandat donc il ya encore des choses à
faire et puis j'ai même si c'était
nécessaire de se mettre à travailler de
cette façon là un peu la frustration
d'avoir eu ces deux années de qu'ovide
où j'ai le sentiment de ne pas être allé
au bout de ce qu'on pouvait faire au
master 2 est une sorte de parenthèse
c'est une sorte de parenthèse j'espère
qu'on va sortir très prochainement de la
crise mais de toute évidence c'est aussi
une motivation supplémentaire pour me
dire il ya des choses qu'on doit pouvoir
encore faire bouger et que la crise
sanitaire nous a un peu empêché qu'est
ce que vous avez appris pendant cinq ans
c'est une très bonne question que
c'était un mandat très très riches parce
que
forcément en étant élu à 26 ans découvre
vraiment plein de choses mais
si je pouvais me permettre dire quelque
chose de positif et peut-être quelque
chose qui m'a un peu choqué le positif
c'est finalement la volonté des gens de
continuer de s'engager quelle que soit
la forme de l'engagement mais de
chercher à faire bouger des lignes j'ai
bien sûr vu des maires des associations
mais j'ai aussi vu des chefs
d'entreprises qui avaient envie par
exemple de beaucoup plus travaillé sur
le modèle social au sein de leur
entreprise de dire quelle place on
accorde à nos salariés comme on fait
pour qu'ils restent sur la formation des
jeunes comment s comme ça je trouve que
finalement souvent on a l'impression que
on a une perte un peu d'engagement en
france moi je crois qu'elle est toujours
là elle s'exprime par différentes formes
et il faut peut-être travailler sur
comment est ce qu'on la valorise mais
j'ai toujours vu des gens là qui était
qu'ils étaient motivés dans leur projet
dans leurs ambitions et qui avait envie
de les exprimer et aussi cette volonté
du coup une fine et de faire réussir
notre pays ce qui m'a peut-être le plus
choqué dans ce mandat là en revanche et
on est aujourd'hui dans un moment où je
crois que on est parfois on fait face à
une forme de refus de débat d idées on a
l'impression que le fait d'avoir
quelqu'un en face de nous qui n'est pas
d'accord c'est presque une agression
parfois de course voilà que ça se
traduit par une graine de violence que
ça
je crois qu'on l'a vu au moment d'aider
gilet jaune le terme à la violence dans
la société française une formule telle
capacité à dialoguer je trouve voyez
beaucoup plus que ce que eric zemmour
ait said agité comme un totem beaucoup
plus que l'immigration pour la question
du vivre ensemble et d'accepter
finalement que l'autre ait des
différences qu'il n'ait pas les mêmes
points de vue que c'est ça aussi qui
fait la richesse de notre pays je crois
que ça c'est vraiment de challenge et
aujourd'hui et c'est un vrai sujet vous
avez 26 ans quand vous avez été élu donc
très jeune il y a quand même le risque
même dans des élections présidentielles
d'une forte abstention des jeunes
peut-être parce qu'il s'engage ailleurs
d'ailleurs à vous le vous le disais il
ya d'autres formes d'engagement mais
qu'est ce que vous leur dernier pour
pour les convaincre de venir voter il
faut vivait une nouveauté alors je veux
dire un argument très basique c'est qu'à
partir du moment où vous rentrez dans la
vie active vous pouvez être soumis à
l'impôt et donc en tant que ce qui fait
votre contribution au pays
donc ce qui justifie finalement le fait
que vous participiez le choix et aux
orientations politiques de votre votre
pays vous devenez un contribuable et à
ce titre là vous avez vous avez le droit
au chapitre je crois qu'il faut se
saisir de cette opportunité la deuxième
chose peut-être que j'ai envie de leur
dire c'est que on a tendance à dénigrer
un peu l'engagement politique à
considérer peut-être parfois les
politiques un peu comme des voyous comme
des gens qui sont là pour leur intérêt
personnel je crois que venez-vous
confrontés aux débats venez regarder
n'ayez pas peur aussi de poser des
questions et considérer que votre
jeunesse est une force finalement dans
ce débat politique parce que moi je les
ai vus je crois qu'on a essayé beaucoup
d'agir on a parfois fait des erreurs
mais aussi il ya ce regard un peu
bienveillant des gens qui considèrent
qu' il vaut mieux s'engager que de
rester sur le sur le sur le bord de la
route enfin je sais pas si j'aurai
réussi à convaincre beaucoup de jeunes
de 18 à 25 ans on va dire qu'ils sont
peut-être ceux sur lequel il faut le
plus travaillé mais au cours de ce
mandat là j'ai été dans plus de quarante
deux classes différentes et
principalement chez des cm2 parce que ça
fait partie de leur programme
d'éducation civique aussi chez des
collégiens et des lycéens plutôt sur des
cm2 et quand on m'a demandé mais
pourquoi au fait ça parce que finalement
c'est pas dans une démarche politique
j'y vais pour leur parler de mon métier
de la fonction de ce que je fais mais si
on veut que les plus jeunes
s'intéressent finalement un jour à la
vie politique il faut leur expliquer à
quoi sert chacun le maire le député etc
et je pense que c'est très important
qu'on se pose cette question de dire
finalement est ce qu'on est sûr que
notre jeunesse connaît le fonctionnement
des institutions jeu très frappé parfois
de voir que c'est rien ne savent pas
quand on s'approche d'un d'éducation il
ya un point de l'éducation et du coup
peut-être que les oiseaux cinq ans il y
aura une très forte abstention mais
j'espère que j'aurai participer
finalement à la formation de ces futurs
électeurs en leur disant d'une bas quand
vous êtes jeunes vous pouvez vous
engager vous pouvez était dû vous pouvez
exercer des responsabilités et parfois
ça démarre très jeune puisque dès le
conseil municipal des jeunes dans
l'écologie
et puis et puis
c'est important c'est fondamental que
mon nez des gens qui fassent vivre le
débat politique en parler de ce qui se
passe est un peu en dehors de la
politique on a eu ce week-end ce n'est
un bon convoi de la liberté alors
finalement ça s'est plutôt bien passé si
je veux dire enfin il ya pas eu de
blocage comment comme il y en a eu au
moment des faits les jaunes mais
on voit bien que ces mouvements se
déroule un peu en dehors de la vie
politique elle même est ce que est ce
que vous il ya un risque ou craignent un
risque de d'explosion sociale
le risque il est il est toujours présent
parce qu'on voit bien collectivement
dans un moment de tension et c'est vrai
que la crise sanitaire les restrictions
que nous avons parfois été contraints
d'imposer à nos concitoyens
sont aussi parfois difficile à vivre et
donc il ne faut pas négliger finalement
les différentes formes de colère qui
peuvent s'exprimer il faut être toujours
à l'écouté je crois d et des besoins
ce que je fais effectivement je pense
qu'il faut souligner que déjà l'ordre a
été maintenu et c'est très important je
pense aux forces de l'ordre ou aussi
permis à la fois les gens qui voulaient
manifester puisse le faire il s'est
exprimé leur point de vue et en même
temps ce qui vous déplaît que plus belle
et en même temps que ça ça ne devienne
pas la chance que ça je crois que c'est
fondamental
il ya une forme de débat qui se passe en
dehors il ya des revendications des gens
qui considèrent aujourd'hui que
il n'arrive plus à participer à la vie
politique ils n'y sont plus associés
alors à la fois y ait la responsabilité
individuelle il faut aller voter si vous
votez pas vous ne pouvez pas participer
mais aussi je crois ce devoir d'aller
aussi pour la de la part des élus quelle
que soit l'heure lors leur place
d'ailleurs dans la vie démocratique
d'aller à la rencontre de ces gens de
les écouter j'ai trouvé pour ça que le
grand débat national était un exercice
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'il
faisait revenir dans la discussion des
gens qui n'avaient pas l'habitude d'y
être donc ils viennent pas au meeting
politique que ce soit au niveau national
ou réunions publics on peut qu'on peut
organiser
des gens qu'ils ne se sentent pas
concernés qui le disent ne pas s'y
intéresser je trouve d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui qu'un certain nombre de
chaînes nationales
organise des formats d'un cadre de cette
campagne où ils font venir des gens qui
traditionnellement participent moins à
la vie politique soit parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le temps pour des contraintes
familiales professionnelles soit parce
qu'ils considèrent qu'ils ne sont pas
qui ne sont pas impliqués je crois que
on doit en tout cas tout faire pour se
dire que par les eaux en tout cas là le
globe de ce débat il doit à un moment
revenir dans la vie politique maker ça
peut d'abord se traduire par une
manifestation mais il faut à tout prix
chercher à éviter ce qu on en a eu dans
le cadre du mouvement des gilet jaune
tout un tas de revendications qui
s'agrège est en fait finalement une
incapacité à l'osq entre entre ce que
vous faites de la politique et ça c'est
notre c'est notre devoir réussir ta
famille il ya dans leur éducation fo qui
avait avait des vidéos beaucoup d'anti
va arriver aussi il y a un problème qui
est celui du pouvoir d'achat qui est
central dans la campagne électorale
l'envol prix de l'essence qui qui qui
monte est-ce qui excuse pour six ans de
prendre des mesures
rapides
il ya eu des choix il ya déjà eu des
mesures en matière enfin
d'accompagnement qui était nécessaire et
pour faire face notamment à la flambée
des prix aux mamans au monde est fait et
je crois que c'était des mesures utiles
efficaces qui ont permis un peu de
redonner un peu d'oxygène ensuite il y a
la réalité c'est que quand vous écoutez
un petit peu les spécialistes de
l'énergie on ne va pas aller vers une
décroissance immédiate de ces prix de
l'essence ou de l'énergie plus plus
globalement et donc il y a deux choses
que nous pouvons faire l'accompagnement
à long terme et c'est ce qu'on veut
faire quand le président fait un
discours fort en matière de nucléaire
c'est à dire il faut qu'on soit beaucoup
plus indépendants en matière de
production de notre énergie et moi j'ai
constaté pendant ce mandat là que les
gens sont partis les français sont très
attachés au nucléaire et on doit
répondre a finalement ce défi qui est
devant nous et c'est une bonne réponse
et puis ensuite il y a on va dire des
mesures moyen terme c'est effectivement
être en capacité de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux gens et nous nous nous avons
fait des mesures pour le pouvoir d'achat
mais nous croyons aussi fondamentalement
que le pouvoir d'achat il passe rappard
la création d'emploi la création de de
l'implantation de sites dantin
entreprises et sites industriels sur
notre territoire et ça je crois qu'on a
créé les conditions pour pour le faire
on a aussi créé les conditions pour
mieux associer les salariés aux
résultats de l'entreprise en modifiant
la participation et l'intéressement est
donc maintenant notre rôle c'est
d'aiguillonner un peu les entreprises
pour qu'elles réfléchissent parce que
contrairement à ce que certains essayent
de vous faire croire la question du
salaire dépend essentiellement de
l'entreprise c'est à nous des guyanes
est un peu les entreprises pour leur
dire on fait des dispositifs qui vous
permettent de mieux rémunérer vos
salariés il faut que vous vous en seriez
crois que ça c'est très c'est très
important et puis après tout les mesures
d'accompagnement par exemple pour
pouvoir acheter un véhicule électrique
si vous en avez le choix est pour
pouvoir si vous êtes notamment un
citadin pouvoir bénéficier de d'un vélo
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya une tension
aussi sur le marché du vo de ces
exemples comme il ya tout un tas de dead
qui existe est peut-être d'ailleurs
notre devoir c'est de les simplifier
pour être sûr que tout ce qu'ils veulent
et élit le soir et puis à les
accompagner après il allait tout ce qui
touche à une meilleure isolation de
votre logement il ya tout un tas dette
qui existe ma prime renner vous rêvez
pas c'est parfois compliqué mais voilà
notre mission c'est tout simple de faire
connaître ces dispositifs de les
rappeler régulièrement à nos concitoyens
qui veulent s'en saisir et puis de les
rendre simples et efficaces pour que ce
soit pas une montagne administratif pour
y être éligible alors on va parler de la
présidentielle à la romance suspense est
ce que emmanuel macron sera candidat
il ya eu une sorte de règle dans l'eau
dans la vème république c'est à dire
c'est que les présidents qui exerçait le
pouvoir dont jamais été réélu des deux
seuls qui sont à terre et lui ces mythes
et enrichira qui étaient des prix des
autres cohabitation dont c'était en
quelque sorte des candidats de
l'opposition se sont présentés qu'est ce
qui vous fait penser que emmanuel macron
pourrait rompre avec cette sorte de loi
terrible
seydoux veut centeno difficile non mais
déjà je souhaite qu'il soit candidat
parce que je pense qu'on a un très bon
bilan et qu'on doit le défendre je
souhaite
non mais je viens c'est à lui de se
prononcer sur le sujet mais il a un bon
bilan et je crois qu'on est tout à fait
légitime à des ventes à la fois un très
bon bilan avant la crise et aussi et ça
a été largement salué par ceux qui ont
pu en bénéficier de mesures
d'accompagnement et de et de la relance
pendant cette cette crise ensuite je
crois que c'est la crédibilité
finalement du président de la république
la solidité aussi de son discours la
prévisibilité la clarté de ce qu'on a
dit le fait qu'on n'a pas dérogé de
notes ligne qui doit je crois à la fois
donner confiance à ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour nous et même plus largement
donné confiance à tous les français pour
dire nous on a une ligne claire peut
être beaucoup plus que d'autres
candidats et je pense notamment à la
candidate des républicains valérie
pécresse on a démontré que cette
politique on était en capacité de la
tenir elle a démontré aussi ses
résultats on le voit par le chômage on
le voit par le nombre d'emplois créés on
le voit par le fait qu on est le premier
pays européen qui soit le plus attractif
on le voit sur la scène internationale
contre le président va discuter avec
vladimir poutine et le président
ukrainien et donc tout ça on a su
démontrer pendant cinq ans la stature du
chef de l'état sa solidité et je crois
que voilà on est aussi dans un moment on
a besoin de cette forme de continuité
donc ce sera aux électeurs de et de
décider mais j'espère qu'en tout cas ces
cinq années auront prouvé je crois à la
force des manuels mâcon pour exercer 7,7
cette mission que la présence de
république on a souvent dit qu'il était
un peu seul
est-ce que vous avez vous êtes de ceux
qui l'auront pas dire et est-ce que
voilà est-ce qu'ils devraient peut-être
peut être mieux accompagnés alors est ce
que votre option si jamais elle était
rayonnante je crois et ça n'empêche pas
d'associer d'autres acteurs mais je
crois une forme de verticalité moi je
pense que en france nous avons un chef
qui dirige
comme pouvait dire chirac et je crois
que c'est très important de pas tout
mélanger ça ne veut pas dire discuter
avec les parties prenantes ça ne veut
pas dire exclure les élus locaux mais je
crois que c'est très important
d'accepter une part de verticalité dans
le la gestion du pouvoir ensuite je
crois pas qu'il soit seul on a six jeux
si je prends on voit bien à l'occasion
de la course aux parrainages comme on
l'appelle des ralliements je pense à
eric woerth la maire de calais au maire
de la mairie du neuf est 9e et 10e
arrondissements de marseille donc il ya
des gens qui n'étaient pas des soutiens
de la première heure et qui continue de
lui apporter son soutien il a une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale il a
des élus locaux aussi dans les
territoires et la preuve c'est que nous
avons très rapidement engranger les 500
soutien nécessaires à sa candidature ce
qui prouve aussi notre présence dans les
territoires et puis enfin il a aussi
un mouvement aussi le soutien qui
l'accompagné qui reste aujourd'hui
probablement le mouvement le plus
dynamique vous savez moi je suis depuis
près de deux mois sur est bien géré le
match et là ça marche très bien et la
réalité c'est que nous sommes seuls
aujourd'hui sur le terrain ça aussi
c'est important pour le débat d'idées à
les rencontrer les gens dans leur
quotidien échangé avec eux de débattre
moi aujourd'hui je ne vois aucun autre
parti politique qui fait ça dans ma
circonscription et donc ça prouve aussi
la vitalité de ce mouvement qui est la
république en marche enfin je crois
qu'il a été accompagné au cours de ce
mandat par des personnalités qui osent
dont l'action est particulièrement
reconnue je pense à edouard philippe une
crédibilité qu'il a perdue de l'est de
drogue préférée des français qui
comptent et une crédibilité aussi sur la
scène internationale où je crois la
france alors bien sûr c'est la
présidence française de l'union
européenne en ce moment mais aussi très
regardée par nos partenaires européens
pour finalement donner une voix à cette
union européenne fils qui parfois peut
manquer un peu de présence sur la scène
internationale justement la scène
internationale il ya quand même le
risque de l'invasion de l'ukraine ou
d'une partie de l'ukraine par la russie
et par poutine si jamais par malheur ça
arrive et est ce que ça change quelque
chose d'abord
il faut que le président président et
président jusqu'au bout et son rôle sera
probablement enfin est déjà très
important à cette crise internationale
est ce qu'il peut faire campagne et en
même temps
compliquée est ce que ça va avoir une
influence au fond sur les sur les
électeurs et je crois que c'est très
important que le président soit
effectivement pleinement engagé dans
l'apaisement de la situation entre la
russie et l'ukraine moi je suis assez
inquiète de la part d'un certain nombre
de nos responsables politiques qui
estiment qu'on à ostraciser la russie
qu'on n'a pas respecté et que finalement
il faudrait céder à toutes les
revendications de vladimir poutine et ne
pas considérer finalement aussi le point
de vue des ukrainiens ne serait ce que
pour amorcer une désescalade je crois
que le dialogue était engagé par le
président entre les deux pays en se
faisant l'intermédiaire de ces deux pays
est une très bonne façon de faire
puisque l'ukraine c'est le cren et la
russie mais particulièrement l'ukraine
c'est aux portes de l'union européenne
et il faut considérer que c'est l'europe
aussi qui doit être le médiateur dans
cette danse est
dans cette guerre qui se profile ou qui
pourrait se profiler et que donc le
président en tant que actuellement
président du conseil de l'union
européenne à
tous sont où son rôle a exercé ensuite
on a toujours eu ce débat pendant la
crise sanitaire notamment de savoir si
oui ou non notre vie démocratique devait
s'arrêter je crois que c'est extrêmement
important qu'on se bat pour défendre
notre vie démocratique et donc de
préserver les jeunes car il faut
préserver des sciences quoi qu'il arrive
ça c'est le président est 100% engagé
dans la désescalade détention qu'il est
entre la russie et l'ukraine et je crois
et je crois que c'est une erreur de
penser linverse qu'il pourra à la fois
être candidat puisque c'est quelque
chose qui concerne la vie politique
française et que c'est très important
que chacun puisse exprimer à l'occasion
de ce vote s'ils souhaitent soutenir ou
non le président de la république pour
soutenir tout autre candidat et en même
temps considéré que jusqu'à la dernière
minute il est président de la république
et qu'à ce titre il est légitime pour
porter la voix de la france et de
l'union européenne sur la scène
internationale
on va peut-être parlé un petit peu de
vocaux qu il y avait le betting 2 les
pécresse au zénith vous l'avez regardé
bout en bout
je trouve ça très bon ce n'est pas très
long terme de timing ça a duré une heure
et demie je crois pas prêt
mais j'ai trouvé ça dans la droite ligne
de ce que faisait les républicains et la
candidate depuis le début de cette
campagne un naufrage à la fois sur la
forme et sur le fond on nous a beaucoup
dit vous allez voir valérie pécresse va
emmener la salle va entraîner la foule
etc et ce n'est pas du tout trouvé cet
élan et je crois que c'était assez
partagé par les commentateurs de la vie
politique et si on passe cette question
de la forme qui peut être un peu cruel
et qu'on s'intéresse au fond moi qui
suis plutôt issus de la droite je ne me
retrouve absolument pas dans les idées
qui sont portées je suis très inquiète
que cette théorie du grand remplacement
qui est quand même une théorie qu'une
telle thibault qui la théorie reporté
par exem moore puissent être reprises
cours
d'un parti qui est censé incarner le
centre droit et donc on voit bien que
finalement il ya une forme de course à
l'échalote entre eric zemmour marine le
pen et valérie pécresse si la critique
d'eric woerth d'ailleurs quand tu sais
la critique des rigueurs tout à fait et
je crois que les électeurs de centre
droit ceux qui veulent incarner des
valeurs libérale pro européenne
qui croient à l'innovation qui croit au
développement qui croient au partage de
la valeur
c'est que ceux qui ont ces convictions
là je pense que doivent se retrouver
dans la personne du président de la
république et d'ailleurs on le voit bien
contrairement aux autres candidats qui
font un peu le yoyo depuis qu'on a des
sondages à la proche de la
présidentielle emmanuel à venir ils sont
habiles c'est très solide autour de
entre 24 et 26 mai à dire qui prouve
bien que le fait aussi qu'on ait pas
varié dans nos convictions rassure
énormément les français il ya un mot
peut-être eric zemmour il ya pas mal de
gens qui sont sur le terrain qui disent
comme ça qu'ils rencontrent beaucoup
d'électeurs qui est des huiles disco
peut-être un peu dur mais au fond
finalement il d'aider des choses vraies
est-ce que
vous pensez vous craignez d'ailleurs
peut-être qu'il soit peut-être un peu
sous-évalué par les sondages que les
sondeurs et un peu de mal à
comprendre ce phénomène achever une
spécialiste de la fin c'est ce qu'on
vous dit ça dans les soldes je suis pas
je suis pas une spécialiste de la façon
dont son son et en scène j'ai compris
que maintenant c'était beaucoup en
dématérialisé ce qui a incité les gens
peut-être à dominer plus facilement
leurs convictions peuple plutôt que par
téléphone avec un intermédiaire ce qui
ont peu a parfois avoir le sentiment
d'être un peu jugé
donc je pense qu'il est évalué à ce
qu'il est capable de faire entre 13 et
15% on verra après voilà
j'entends effectivement ce discours sur
le terrain de dire il soulève des bonnes
questions mais pardon mais en fait c'est
là où pour moi il ya une différence très
claire entre le métier de polémiste sur
un plateau télé et le métier de
responsable politique
moi je ne crois pas qu'ils soulèvent des
vrais sujets est ce que la question de
la sécurité doit être dans le débat de
la présidentielle de toute évidence
c'est une fonction régalienne de l'état
ne pas parler de la sécurité serait une
faute est ce que la question de
l'immigration doit faire partie du débat
politique tout à fait je veux dire c'est
notre capacité à intégrer à accueillir à
accueillir des dans des bonnes
conditions à trouver un emploi à trouver
un logement bien sûr que ça doit être
dans le dans le débat c'est une évidence
donc pour moi parler de ces deux sujets
n'est pas dire on soulève des bonnes
questions on l'a fait pendant tout le
mandat on a fait la loi asile
immigration on à fait différentes lois
en faveur de la sécurité on a redonné du
budget à notre justice and m'a redonné
du budget à nos gendarmes et à nos
forces de police donc ces questions
elles ont été traitées tout au long du
quinquennat et c'est pas parce que eric
zemmour à un discours scandaleux que
tout d'un coup le sujet je m'en serais
mis sur la table ou que
tous les prédécesseurs de régler moore
quels qu'ils soient et emmanuel macron
enfin le président barack big où ses
prédécesseurs n'ont rien fait je pense
que c'est une faute de dire ça aux au
demeurant j'ai l'intimé conviction que
désigner un coupable pour justifier de
toutes nos faiblesses et ne pas
s'interroger sur les vraies couilles si
oui voilà de ce qui fait que des biens
peut-être notre balance commerciale
n'est pas encore excédentaire peu les
routes avec qui son logement problème
pour la plupart des gens qui habitent
dans les grandes villes que la question
du coût de l'énergie est un sujet que la
question de la rémunération est un sujet
et moi quand j'écoute eric zemmour et
que la seule réponse et on va arrêter
les migrations et on dégagera des marges
budgétaires comme ça je trouve ça non
seulement très inquiétant est aussi une
absence totale de réponses aux
problématiques des français
comme les gens en parlent de tout et oui
les gens phénomène médiatique c'est vrai
maintenant je prends parfois un peu
inquiète j'ai l'impression qu'on
n'écoute pas ce qu'eric zemmour a
raconté et je trouve que c'est il faut
vraiment écouté son discours et se
rendre compte à quel point c'est
inquiétant pour à notre pays une
dernière question peut-être alors plus
plus de politique enfin vous me disiez
20 et le maquereau est à peu près 24 25
% les autres 16 17% donc le président
élu quels qu'ils soient il va avoir à
peu près une 20% de partisans
c'est compliqué de réformer la france
compte en a pas plus dès le premier tour
parce que après les au deuxième tour les
gens votent contre l'adversaire aussi
pour grande partie est ce qu'il faudrait
pas réformé pour avoir des alliances
plus forte je passe sur quatre ou cinq
réformes voire un peu des gouvernements
qui dépasse la la la les le pourcentage
de voix du premier tour du président
des ja je joue réformer la france quoi
si on veut réformer parce qu'on voit
bien que quand on commence à réformer on
a 60 pour cent cinquante 50 % des gens
qui sont contre vous quoi je crois et
c'est vous me posez la question à
l'heure qu'est ce que j'ai appris au
cours de ce mois là je crois que il ne
faut jamais nier la difficulté d'engager
une réforme
et c'est pas parce qu'on est un peuple
qui veut pas se réformer on est un
peuple qui veut beaucoup de
transformations mais
nous avons un système qui est complexe
qui est riche et qui je crois aussi
quand vous vous engager une réforme
sacré et ça génère de l'incertitude sur
votre avenir l'avenir de chacun et donc
il est légitime que elle suscite des
oppositions des interrogations des
questionnements dévoile tout ça est est
parfaitement légitime et le rôle du
politique c'est c'est difficile sur les
chaînes d'information d'être capable de
dépasser la polémique de la petite
phrase le basser levante amendement qui
fait kiffer plus polémique que
l'ensemble du texte de loi est de
réussir à expliquer finalement quel est
le projet que l'on souhaite porter
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait cette réforme
quels sont les paramètres qui vont
bouger et c'est ensuite sur la question
de la légitimité
déjà je voudrais quand même en est ce
que j'entends tous nos adversaires
d'hier bah oui il sera élu qu'avec aller
25 % du corps électoral qui lui sera
favorable la réalité c'est que il n'y
aura enfin si on est élu avec 25 % du
corps électoral ne calculait l'ensemble
des pourcentages des autres pour dire
ils représentent le reste représente 80%
c'est faux puisque personne ne
s'allierait jamais on voit bien déjà les
difficultés de la gauche a sali et puis
ensuite oui il charge après je pense au
futur président la république et on le
voit depuis nicolas sarkozy de faire des
ouvertures dans son gouvernement le
président république l'a fait lorsqu'il
a choisi comme premier ministre
jean castex qui est un ancien de
notamment de sarkozy
donc il a fait je pense d ouverture il y
à aussi audi du soft qui nous a rejoint
au début du mandat et qui a été
initialement élus pour le parti
socialiste qui était un député du parti
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale mais
ça c'est vous dire que c'est des
débauchages individuels
est ce qu'il y aurait à une réforme à
faire pour que y ait plus d'alliances à
l'assemblée plus de peut-être sur des
projets précis sur des
ce que ça serait pas plus facile pour
gouverner un peu comme ce que regarder
ce qui se passe en allemagne on voit
bien québec comprend ce que sur le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée nationale
si je pense qu'on a tendance à oublier
la diversité des groupes à l'assemblée
nationale qui représente finalement les
tendances nous avons des alliés le modem
agir avec qui parfois nous sommes en
désaccord globalement nous avançons
ensemble mais parfois nous sommes
d'accord nous avons parfois des
alliances avec le parti socialiste avec
la droite et puis moi je crois que
dans la recherche du consensus pour bien
sûr vous avez raison apaisé en quelque
sorte le débat peut-être faire passer
plus facilement une réforme il faut pas
aussi nié que parfois le consensus peut
un peu de tuer le débat moi
aujourd'hui j'aime beaucoup travailler
avec un sénat qui finalement en
opposition un petit peu avec le
président de la république il faut être
en capacité d'avancer parfois le sénat a
plutôt démontré qu'ils le freinage pense
à la réforme de l'action qui aura été
importante mais j'ai aussi trouvé dans
certains projets de loi que finalement
le fait d'avoir une assemblée nationale
qui ne soit pas de la même couleur
politique que le sénat venait vraiment
enrichir le débat moi je crois que la
politique c'est le débat d'idées c'est
la recherche du compromis et ça se fait
aussi entre entre personnes qui qui ne
sont pas d'accord et qui viennent avec
leurs convictions qui sont fortes et
donc vous avez raison sur le fait dire
il faut chercher le consensus parce que
c'est ce qui permet aussi de mieux
expliquer une réforme mais je crois que
cette recherche de consensus elle existe
aussi déjà au chalet entre entre les
deux chambres parce que il ya beaucoup
il faut il faut il faut accepter cette
idée de dire la discussion et le temps
politique ça prend du temps rien ne se
fait en claquant des doigts aucune
réforme ne se fait facilement mais c'est
ça qui fait la richesse de la vie
politique c'est à dire on discute on
avance on trouve un équilibre et c'est
ça qui m'a plu aussi à la réplique en
marche c'est finalement il ya des gens
qui viennent de la droite des mois qui
viennent de la gauche certains parfois
gagne sur on discute et on essaye de on
trouve toujours un atterrissage entre
nous quand un des députés on a des
journées de dingue on a des journées
bien remplies de toute évidence non non
c'est franchement c'est très intense
comme rythme et
je joue je crois que la principale
qualité d'un député c'est d'avoir une
bonne santé pour pouvoir suivre ce
rythme effréné on vous souhaite une
bonne santé ça merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup marie d'office merci
[Musique]